How many times per day can I run my day programs?
Well, you could run your day programs over and over and over and over throughout the day.
So there isn't a limit to running your day programs. The only thing that I would say is if
you are going to be fairly non-ambulatory and you're going to be sitting and reading for
considerable length of time, let's say eight hours, just run your night program again,
so you don't have to hit, you know, open up your computer and hit run because your day programs are
only an hour to two hours long. So then just run your night program if you're going to be sitting
there for a long time. So, um, but let's say you got two hours here and other two hours later on
and another two hours tonight before you go to bed, then go ahead and run your day programs three times.
I've always said you could explore other programs if you have other cold morbidities, you know,
you might have an infection or you might have, you know, you feel like cold is coming on or something
like that. Go ahead and run those programs at your will. Especially if your cancer is, you know,
do eat well, but if your cancer is, you know, not in the do eat well phase and it is a very active
that I would spend the majority of my time running cancer programs. When I was in the throes of my
cancer, I was only running my cancer programs and I was running at, you know, at night, actually,
as soon as I got home, I was so, you know, I just, I was still going to work, but I was basically
working from my desk like I'm sitting right now the entire day. So I was running my right at the
office. I had a rife running and I ran that the whole day and I went home and when I was really ill,
I wasn't doing anything. I was going home and sitting in my chair and turned down the rife and I was
running the rife and then when I went to bed, I turned it out. So I was literally running it almost
24-7 when I was in the throes of it. I mean, obviously, I wasn't 24-7 because I was, you know, living,
you know, up and doing stuff. But every time I was sitting doing nothing, which when I was really sick,
it was a lot of time when I was sitting doing a whole little lot of nothing, I was running the
rife. So, you know, when you're in the throes of the cancer, the more rife time you could get the
better chance you have that survival. So, I really believe that it was the action of the rife
machine that put me in the state of remission that I'm in right now. So, don't not run your rife
when you are sitting. Now, I do want you to be living it up and doing things and living your life. But
if you are exhausted, you have to sit down and you're going to rest and I got to I'll go read a book or
I'm going to read my Bible, then turn out the rife and be doing you're running the rife.